hi I'm Mike Walter I'm the senior
director of the Explorer's guide to
biology at the science communication lab
I grew up in a small town in Northern
Ontario called Sudbury it's a mining
town
and so most of my family did mining in
the area
my experience as a first generation
scientist Was Not Unusual I don't think
I didn't find it unusual to go to
university even though I was the first
member of my immediate family to go to
university
it was something I always wanted to do
ever since I was a young boy I remember
being 10 years old going to little ponds
near where I lived collecting frog eggs
bringing them back and I would watch the
eggs hatch become tadpoles and this this
sort of question about how does this
work how did this happen sort of
motivated me and since I was 10 years
old I wanted to be a scientist I wanted
to know how biology worked I started
University at a universe the University
of Guelph which is in the southern part
of Ontario in Canada I majored in
genetics after doing this undergraduate
degree I went to the medical genetics
department at the University of Toronto
I interviewed with several different
people there ultimately I settled on the
lab of a woman called Dr Diane Cox and
so my PhD was on trying to understand
some of the biology and genetics
associated with the genes that make
antibodies
after finishing my PhD at the University
of Toronto I wanted to do my postdoc
into a different country and the lab
that really struck me as the most
interesting was that of Dr Peter
Goodfellows so Dr Peter Goodfellow was
at the icrf in London and he was really
interested in sex discrimination and the
genes that were responsible for it I
thought it was a fascinating project and
so I was accepted to his lab I worked
with him for three years during that
time we and the other postdocs in the
lab identified the gene called sry for
sex region Y chromosome and so it was a
fundamental discovery that sort of paved
the way for our understanding at least
in mammals of how sex determination
works while I was just finishing my
postdoc in England I wanted to return
back to Canada I ended up settling and
accepting an offer from the University
of Alberta and I stayed there Rising
through the ranks doing research and
teaching up until the time where I
joined the Explorer's guide to biology
and this allows me to pursue my passion
of bringing
biology and the teaching of biology and
The Wonder of biology to a new
generation of students